hi i'm kristen tomlin better known as
the founder and ceo of dough cookie
dough confections
welcome to pro tips from pro chefs
today we're in the kitchen and i'm
teaching you how to take ingredients
like your favorite cereal
and make it into the most delicious
edible cookie dough
i thought what better way to celebrate
national cookie dough day than to demo
for you how to make really amazing
edible cookie dough i'm always in the
kitchen baking
and what happens if you run out of flour
don't worry
don't fear you can grab your favorite
cereal whatever you like
and we're going to turn it into flour
and we're going to use it instead of the
flour in this edible cookie dough recipe
it's going to be delicious
it's going to taste just like that bowl
of cereal that you love in the morning
maybe a little bit sweeter i'm going to
take one of my favorites
how colorful and fun and we're going to
turn this into flour
i am going to be using this food
processor here but if you don't have a
food processor at home you could do this
in a blender and if you don't have a
blender you can also just grab
a ziploc bag like this put the cereal in
it
and then a rolling pin or honestly even
a glass of wine
just go to town and you're going to
break it up until it's
little tiny pieces just like flour i'll
show you how to do it in here
this thing makes it super quick and then
it's exactly the right texture it's
really fine it still has that
fun rainbow color and this is going to
go straight into our cookie dough that
we've already made
so we got all of that stuff out of the
way we're ready to put this in the mixer
i've made my cookie dough it's safe to
eat and edible and now we're just gonna
add
all of that fun flavor the base of this
is basically a sugar cookie
except whatever cereal you're gonna use
that's the flavor profile that's going
to come through
so just turn your mixer on slowly pour
in
your cereal little by little and let the
mixer do the hard work
you could also use a hand mixer if you
want or you'll get a serious arm workout
oh my gosh this smells so so yummy
and that's it let me show you guys
exactly what this looks like
because this is edible and bakeable you
could make this into cookies too
you could go ahead and lick this paddle
yum i love how colorful this is
it smells delicious you could even throw
in some white chocolate chips some
yogurt chips if you're really going for
that morning vibe
this one is ready to eat and if you
don't happen to have cereal in your
cabinet
you could always grab your favorite
cookies so
these cookies and cream is one of my
absolute favorite flavors
i've already made this one i've done the
same thing with these cookies just
pulverized it until it's really really
fine flour
and then mixed it together into my
cookies and cream
cookie dough how delicious you can eat
this right away or you can save some
later to bake in the oven for more fun
tips head to thedrewberrymoreshow.com
or grab my cookbook hello cookie dough
lots of fun treats in here
and tune in for more tips from pro chefs
[Music]
you